I've been going through this
metastatic breast cancer journey for over a year with major spine surgery to boot.
I was 125 pounds and now I'm 88 pounds as I just gained two pounds in the last two months of
this journey. I'm literally skinned bones and I've been eating as much protein as I possibly can.
Lately my abdomen is swollen and very hard like I'm pregnant. I don't know
if I didn't realize it before but anything I eat or drink just seems to swell me up.
I eat oatmeal for breakfast with berries, drink a smoothie with greens first for lunch and eat
meat and vegetables for dinner and that's all I can handle. Swelling is gone by is gone by morning.
Is it common for someone by condition experience a distended belly?
Okay so yeah well first of all when you have a serious disease especially when you do
medications or surgery or anything to try to combat that disease you have to deal with the
gut so you have to deal with issues in the gut. The more we fail to deal with the gut I know when
we're hyper focused on killing cancer we can ignore cell of the basics and that is to our
detriment. So a couple things come to mind as first time me reading this question and when
person says I have swollen got look like I'm almost pregnant and it's being distended belly.
My first day is fluid in abdomen but if it's gone by morning then that's not it so that's a good
sign. If it's distension due to inflammation of the gut that would be the next most common thing
is you're going through a series of differential diagnosis it's distension of the gut so you think
of how can you calm down the gut you got to start with some gut healing things you could certainly do
some testing to see if there's any you know foods that are causing inflammation but
baseline support for the gut is as HCl with digestive enzymes so go back to the blog post store
to get in search hypochlorpoidrea. That's your basic support for the gut. If you're not taking HCl
with digestive enzymes with your foods or your eating as much protein as possible protein has to be
broken down, you know, in by a good production of your mark acid and your stomach. So if you don't
have really good production of hydrochloric acid and your stomach, you're not going to be breaking
down your proteins and your stomach. And then you need your pancreas to screen a good amount of
pancreatic enzymes to help break further breakdown that protein into amino acids in the
duodenum in the first part of the small intestine. So helping support that process is important
because we've been through a lot and our body has been ravaged. You know, our stomach decreases
in production of hydrochloric acid, our pancreas is struggling and doesn't produce as much
much digestive enzymes. Our phase three pathway in the liver production of bile is reduced. So we're
not producing as much lipase through bile and we have mal digestion. So supporting digestion,
which is the breakdown of food into particles so that we can absorb it is number one.
Number two is supporting the health of the gut. So adding things like, you know,
muterate and slippery element, we don't want glutamine as a cancer patient but think of things that
will help heal the gut. Diglizarize licorice marshmallow, not marshmallows, craft marshmallows,
they don't work. But the herb, marshmallow and things like that, things that are going to be
gut healing, aloe product that will be gut healing. A good product from Xymagin is this GI
sooth that I talked about a few weeks ago. That is a chewable because it can heal the
esophagus, it can heal the stomach and it can help heal the first part of the small intestine,
which is so important. So taking HCL with digestive enzymes, taking like a GI suit to help heal
the gut and start that healing product process and gut, taking our tributerate from
designs for health that I think it's a tributerate supreme is really good. What do you have
bloated? It's not uncommon that you have sebum, which is small intestinal bacterial overgrowth.
So you've got bacteria that's supposed to be only in the larger intestine, migrates into the
small intestine and that causes problems. Looking at your diet as far as cleaning up gluten and dairy
if you haven't, those are the things that I would look at with distended belly and then digging deeper
if you once you, if person says I'm doing all those things, then if you're doing all those things,
then you start digging deeper and doing the Syrex array 10 panel to see if there's specific foods that
are just causing inflammation or like some people find that there's a lot of foods that are causing
inflammation and it's just getting back to the basics of gut healing is the, there's a key component
is often overlooked when you're trying to deal with the serious disease.